reste très difficile aujourd'hui on se
trouve devant le pont qui relie la ville
à la plage et qui est fermée depuis ce
matin à part pour les résidents et les
premiers répondants donc les conditions
restent extrêmement difficiles ici avec
une connexion cellulaire hasardeuse des
milliers de personnes qui sont toujours
privées de courant et des Floridiens qui
cherchent désespérément de la nourriture
de l'eau potable ou de l'essence et
pendant que les résidents de fortnite
commencent à prendre connaissance de
l'ampleur des dégâts il y a des renforts
de l'extérieur de la Floride qui
viennent prêter mais fortes pour évacuer
les secteurs les plus isolés comme
Pineland ou Sanibel qui sont coupés du
monde depuis mercredi et seulement
accessible par avion ou par bateau
évidemment certains s'inquiètent de voir
le bilan s'alourdir encore plus alors
que les recherches se poursuivent et que
les hélicoptères survolent le secteur et
pendant ce temps d'autres résidents à
qui on a parlé eux sont encore sous le
choc de découvrir leur communauté
complètement défigurée de voir l'ampleur
des dommages je vous laisse écouter des
réactions qu'on a recueillies
aujourd'hui
le président américain Joe Biden est la
première dame sont attendus ici mercredi
pour constater encore une fois l'ampleur
des dégâts avant ça ils vont s'arrêter à
Porto Rico demain Porto Rico qui a été
durement touché par l'ouragan Fiona la
semaine dernière donc on parle de dégâts
chiffrés à des milliards de dollars et
on sait que la reconstruction sera
longue et prendra peut-être même des
années ici la semaine médié Radio-Canada
à forte Myers en Floride